et
on se parle de ça aujourd'hui ça c'est
le nouveau casque de sony c'est le w h
music scene 5 je vous ai déjà parlé de
nombreuses fois des casques de sony w/h
nixon trois thèmes la première
découverte avec ce casque alors il ya eu
double dash indique sam katz est égale
deux ans et là ils viennent de sortir
d'un w h mais l'ex n 5 qui change de
tête il ya des choses vraiment
différente alors aujourd'hui je viens
tout juste de rentrer de lyon j'étais
dans le match des héros
[Musique]
c'était un partenariat au pot unis
certes enfin en tout cas c'était pour
aider les enfants ukrainiens donc voilà
je t'aime faire une vidéo 72 heures dans
la vie d'un créateur youtube je voulais
partager très bientôt sur youtube parce
que je suis ça pourrait être cool de
venir vous montrer un peu les coulisses
comment ça se passe comment se passe mon
job en dehors de ce que vous voyez là
comme ça tout de suite voilà donc ça je
vous le mettre en ligne mais aujourd'hui
on va se concentrer là dessus sur ce
casque là on va regarder si le w h 1805
j'ai utilisé en faisant du sport que
j'utilise dans l'avion que j'utilisais
en balade que j'utilise dans le train
parce que j'ai utilisé je vais vous dire
si l'intérêt sans suite ouvrir tout ce
qui a changé parce que pas mal de choses
qui ont changé vous allez voir le
classement
et pour ça on vient se positionner juste
à la regarder il est juste ici alors w h
music scene 5 qu'est ce qu'il raconte eh
ben c'est un truc qui est assez
intéressant en fait déjà parce qu'on a
un vrai changement par rapport à ce à
quoi ressemble déjà l'étui c'est
différent de ce qu'on avait l'habitude
de retrouver sur le double dash mix am3
blixen cas parce que c'est pas si vous
vous souvenez le w h musique sam 3 lbs
il w/h nixon cap se ressemblait beaucoup
au niveau de la forme c'est quasiment la
même chose et laitues c'était la même
truc là c'est vraiment différent il est
je trouve un peu différents niveaux
l'attend pas extrêmement en plus gros et
surtout ce qui est très différent c'est
le casque en lui même regarder çà çà çà
nasa n'a plus rien avoir du tout avec ce
qu'on avait l'habitude de voir alors
avant de regarder le cas ce regard de
l'intérieur de la boîte on a quoi on va
juste avoir un adaptateur cdu jack jack
hockey facile ça c'est pour se brancher
notamment sans vos écouteurs sans vos
baladeurs et dans les avions au sol des
milliers d'avions s'est pendu trois
points et ensuite eu deux points là je
sais pas vous avez de quoi leur charge
est ici avec de l'usb à versus de l'usb
sais pas ce que vous leur charge est ici
bien évidemment juste en dessous mon usb
c'est vous aimez sur votre prise jack
l'âme on va faire un tour dans quelques
instants et puis voilà c'est tout that's
it c'est tout ok voilà merci au revoir à
leurs trucs qui a fait aussi sony mais
vous le voyez pas parce que je n'ai pas
emmener c'est que la boîte en fait ça le
packaging il est 100% aussi du papier
recyclé donc ya pas de plastique enfin
c'est plutôt cool bon ça c'est pas mal
ça prend un peu de place dans un sac
mais c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
regardez moi par exemple j'ai mon sac là
qui me servent lorsque je pars en
tournage bon il est très grand sac un
bon jeu pour mettre un paquet de trucs
mais hop là voyez je le prends je le
mets là je ferme et puis good to go quoi
comme ça c'est pratique donc mise à
parler de lui en a le casque et le
casque il est différent il est vraiment
différent je trouve je vous le dis je
trouve que sony s'est bonifié ces noms
parce que quand je les ai vus je me suis
dit tiens c'est très très différents le
wh1 hellickson 3104 on avait l'habitude
de prendre plier comme ça ayant plié
comme ça pour le mettre dans la boîte y
avait un truc un peu marrant là ont le
plus plu alors pour autant on reste
quand même sur un art show qu'on peut
quand même venir tort alors le but ce
n'est pas de le tordre n'en peut venir
le bouger pour le mettre sur sa tête
voyait de tous les côtés donc là dessus
on peut le bal mené n'y a pas d'outil ça
bougera pas on a aussi un truc qui sont
lequel ils ont bossé qui vachement
intéressant c'est que cette coulisses la
voyez s'il elle est très silencieuse il
ya un peu moins un bruit de plastique
qu'on avait avant donc ça c'est un point
qu'il aurait avait été demandé
d'améliorer c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ce
que j'aime bien c'est quand on toujours
cette touche un peu premium très premium
d'ailleurs avec les le vhb lixheim
quelque chose avec cette écriture là
qu'on va venir retrouver côté un peu
bronze bronze doré qui est toujours très
élégant et bien articulé au niveau de la
tête regardez up si vous regardez ça
tombe bien d'un côté l'autre donc ça
c'est cool pour le confort ya ce qu'il
faut pour avoir trouvé ici une petite
mousse alors très honnêtement je suis
pas extrêmement convaincu par sa
pourquoi parce que en fait lorsque vous
le mettez plusieurs heures sur votre
tête vous avez un point d'appui et
aujourd'hui je suis vachement habitués à
utiliser mon mémoire podz max est en
fait que le fait d'avoir ce tissu mesh
et bien ça crée pas de point d'appui
sacré pas de truc qui est un peu
lourdingue hélas au bout d'un moment que
ce soit surtout dans le train j'ai passé
plus de trois heures dans le train je le
sent quand même moyen force de l'écouter
alors cherche toujours la bonne position
leurs propres durs on la vend c'est un
peu le recul un petit peu pour trouver
le truc qui va bien ce que je faisais ce
que je mets un peu plus lâché je laisse
un poil remonter là pour que j'ai pas
trop le poids mais ça descend un peu sur
mes oreilles dont je trouve que en fait
c'est pas mal très honnêtement ils ont
bien bossé c'est très haut de gamme mais
c'est vrai ce qu'a fait apple là dessus
avec ce côté tissu mais je trouve que ça
apporte un peu autre chose pour autant
il ya un truc que j'aime pas trop dans
les reposes max et qu'au bout d'un
moment les oreilles les coussins sur les
oreilles vous en pouvait plus et un peu
agressif c'est pas ici qu'on dira ça
frotte en février un truc est pas cool
tandis que là on n'ait vraiment
l'impression d'avoir des espèces de
petites pantoufles et c'est déjà ce que
j'aimais avec les autres casques sais
que vous les mettez ces des pantoufles
pour vos oreilles donc ça se met
vachement bien c'est très doux pour les
oreilles et juste ce point d'appui
lakepa ouf mais bon on s'y fait et on va
pas toujours faire des écoutes pendant
trois heures voilà et après ça dépend de
votre tête moi je sais pas si j'ai une
espèce de bosnie ou un truc mais bon
voilà je le ressens après chacun son sa
forme de crâne ensuite y'a un truc qui
est intéressant c'est qu'ici tout cette
commande la cdu tactile donc j'appuie
deux fois à blade 2 fois pause je monte
le son je baisse le son morceau suivant
morceaux précédents c'est très intuitif
on trouve très très facilement bon c'est
pas un tout qui est tout neuf mais ça
fonctionne bien donc ça c'est cool autre
truc que vous allez avoir c'est que
c'est très minimaliste ici vous avez
juste deux boutons en fait ce qu'en fait
vous avez un bouton bouton marche arrêt
qui est ici qui vous servira pour venir
la paire est très facilement et là c'est
le bouton pour la réduction de bruit
entre noise cancelling à mbé ambiante
sambre il voulait en anglais voulait
s'appuyer vous switchez d'un modèle très
simple ça fonctionne peut pas se tromper
donc je trouve qu'en termes d' usage ce
cas ce que là il est vachement bien
conçu il est très bien fait vous le
prenez vous appuyez tac tac tac musique
vous répondez un appel faites ce que
vous pouvez donc ça c'est cool donc ça
c'est un peu pour la base maintenant il
ya un truc est un peu nouveau et café à
se hisser au niveau de ce cas c'est à
dire qu'ils ont quand même modifier pas
mal de choses à l'intérieur - qui
intéresse quand ils ont changé le
diaphragme on est passé sur un
diaphragme de 30 millimètres alors au
delà du côté extrêmement technique du
nombre de mm du diaphragme l'expérience
elle est toujours très bas toujours au
niveau et on a toujours une superbe
qualité audio alors on va bien
évidemment compléter l'expérience audio
au travers de l'application et notamment
au travers de l'écho à l'isr parce que
je crois que sony c'est la meilleure
expérience audio au niveau de l'equal et
à sion au niveau de l'application qu'on
peut venir retrouver dans son app et je
vais vous montrer ça parce que vraiment
c'est super bien autant vous savez on
est un peu souvent avec bose bosser plus
du plug and play et vous prenez vos
bronches et il ya pas grand chose à face
arrière au temps ça c'est plus un casque
fait pour les passionnés de texte ce
qu'elles deviennent grappiller quelques
paramètres pour venir faire un peu de
teasing avec le dfae extrême donc on a
un truc qui fonctionne très bien en
terme d'autres jours gardé alors là j'ai
pas écouter de la musique au moment où
je vous parle mais je trouve ça marche
vraiment bien c'est à dire qu'on a on a
des médiocres on trouve extrêmement
précis on a des beaux médium les aigus
sont assez fin et ça fonctionne bien et
ça ronronne au niveau des bassins en
autant que ça peut venir au hohneck un
15 août comme ça mais globalement ça va
très bien le riad un truc qu'ils ont
fait ici c'est qu'ils sont passés de 4 à
8 micro sur ce casque là alors l'idée
c'est pas de mettre des micros pour
mettre des micros et j'ai demandé à sony
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a huy micro pour
est-ce que vous avez doublé les micros
est-ce que vous avez vite plus de micro
parce que en fait qu'un certain micro
qui vont dire travailler pour capter
certaines fréquences plutôt que d'autres
pour l'annulation de bruit pour la
réduction bruit active et ils nous ont
dit on vous dit pas on nous ont pas
donné les specs pourquoi comment ça
fonctionne on n'a pas la recette
toujours est il qu'ils sont venus
doubler le nombre de micro alors ce
qu'on peut totalement imaginer parce que
vous savez entre coûts sont très forts
sony c'est sur la réduction de bruit
active on peut se dire ils sont venus
beauce et leurs réductions bruit active
pour améliorer toujours plus leur casque
alors je trouve que ça marche bien mais
c'est pas wmx mk dons je peux pas venir
à comparer directement mais c'est vrai
que ce soit dans un train
que ce soit dans un avion
je trouve que la réduction de bruit et
quand même vachement bonne et fait très
très bien le taf et donc si vous voulez
un super casque de sony avec une très
bonne réduction proactive 8 micro aux
quatre micros je sais pas si ça change
vraiment l'histoire mais en tout cas ça
marche vraiment super bien alors ces
micro et ça revient évidemment pour la
réduction brute mais pas que pour la
réduction de bruit ils vont également
servir si par exemple vous avez du vent
lorsque vous balader dans la rue qui a
du vent qui a soufflé un petit peu mais
ça va venir capté en fait le vans à
venir capter ce qui fait partie de votre
voix je pense pour avoir fait une
meilleure activité au niveau des micros
j'en sais rien du tout pour nous dire
éliminer ce phénomène devant un conte
vous balader pour être vraiment
tranquille donc bon pour moi là dessus
c'est pareil la techno avance et ça
fonctionne alors c'est vrai quand on
parle de sony on va venir souvent se
parler de hell d'ac qui est le codec de
sonic on va venir retrouver entre un
smartphone sony et un casque sony alors
on peut le trouver sur certains
smartphones ce fameux el'dak mais pas
partout beaucoup d'appétit que ça pète
et x hd et compagnie de qualcomm sur un
iphone n'en parlons même pas le sdax
n'existe pas vous l'aurez pas du tout
c'est pas là où vous aurez la meilleure
expérience si vous voulez vraiment
aligner les planètes si vous voulez
vraiment ce cas ce que là ce que je vous
recommande c'est de trouver un
smartphone qui va utiliser le codec ndaq
et notamment sur un smartphone de sony
qui est forcément pas folle la guêpe
alors on va rentrer dans le côté un peu
plus d'écho cela en fait ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est qu'ils ont mis deux
processeurs qui vont bosser pour la
réduction de bruit vous avez le
processeur v1 qui va être coupe le
processeur hdq n 1 et ces deux
processeurs vont bosser ensemble pour
venir optimiser la réduction de bruit
alors globalement sont fous du nombre de
processeurs mais c'est vrai que ça
marche bien et globalement je suis très
satisfait l'expérience là dessus il ya
un autre qui sont dus corrigé par
rapport aux mille xl 4 d'il ya deux ans
c'est à dire qu'en fait un capteur de
présence vous le voyez capteurs présents
c'est quoi c'est lorsque vous prenez
votre casque tac je trouve jamais les
côtés en fait c'est bien écrit si oui
rouge selon white est ici là c'est le
leff cela lorsque vous prenez votre
casque et vous le mettez comme ça lui va
savoir que vous l'avez sur les oreilles
grâce à un capteur de présence qui
permettra lorsque vous le retirez
d'arrêter la musique et au bout d'un
moment vous le verrez dans les
paramètres de l'application c'est à dire
revenir m oppose donc ça c'est très très
pratique et en fait ils ont fait un truc
c'est qu'ils sont venus planqué ce
capteur de présence qu'on voyait
vraiment sur le mix n 4 qui était sur le
côté là je sais plus où mais qu'on
voyait vraiment et alors ils sont durs
beau c'est complètement leur design
intérieur pour le faire disparaître donc
bon ça c'est direz vous un peu de points
de détails mais quand on paye un casque
aussi cher on est content de l'avoir
comme ça et d'ailleurs puisque je vous
parle du capteur de présence assez que
c'est un nouveau capteur qui a été
modifiée qui selon sony sera plus précis
et plus réactif pour autant lorsque la
mairie j'enlève il fonctionne bien est
ce que maintenant je roule la même
expérience avec lance un capteur pour
moi ça marchait déjà très bien en fait
sa marque joue très bien ici pour tout
vous dire j'ai passé la différence mais
bon il est nouveau et ça c'est bien
ouais quand je vous dis cher ces chiens
parce qu'en fait le tarif du casque a
augmenté par rapport aux générations
précédentes ici on est sur un casque qui
va coûter entre 420 euros et 450 euros
ça reste extrêmement charger tout de
suite j'ai pas le prix et j'ai regardé
j'ai checké mes emails ils m'ont pas
envoyer la mise à jour avec le prix
exact entre 420 et 450 euros ça reste
très cher je crois de mémoire que w
chimiques sainte-catherine audacieux
knicks m3 on était à moins de 400 euros
était
a380 ou
360 euros un truc comme ça l'était déjà
quand même très très beau budget on a vu
que apple avec l'arrivée de crp max os
qui l'ont sorti de casque à quoi il ya
un an et demi on était à plus de 600
euros le casque alors qu'ils ont
augmenté le prix c'est probablement
justifiée par toute l'électronique et
tout le travail qui a été fait à
l'intérieur mais c'est vrai que pour le
grand public ça risque d'être très gros
budget ce que vous vous pourriez mettre
entre 420 et 450 euros pour le casque
après il ya des gens qui ont reçu leur
dose max à 6 ans l'autre même si les
prix ont baissé aujourd'hui mais il ya
des consommateurs pour ça et voilà donc
je ne sais pas si vous pourriez mettre
leur dites le moi et si ça vous
intéresse je vous mets un lien en
descriptions sais pas s'il ya sera
disponible au moment où je sortirai la
vidéo mais en tout cas voilà pour
qu'effectivement ça coûte un peu cher
alors regardez l'application elle est là
elle est intéressante en fait
l'application et reprend un petit peu
tous et l'application tel qu'on le
connaissait déjà sais pas si vous avez
déjà lieu qu'est ce que tony c'est la
même chose en fait vous retrouvez
effectivement votre votre casque mois
comme juste sur un iphone je suis en a
assez c'est le codec j'ai pas ici de l
d'alger pas d'appétit et du hamas et
voilà ça c'est un peu le problème sur un
iphone j'ai activé le ds extrêmes le ds
extrême c'est quoi ces deux lobes
scaling up la regarde et je vais
m'activer un tout tout de suite là c'est
parler pour chat est valable explique
tout chat cette fonctionnalité alors moi
je ne trouvais pas complètement dingue
parce que en fait vers laisser ça là
lorsque vous l'activez lorsque vous
parlez bien sam injecte tout le son
extérieur ça me permet de venir
converser avec des gens lorsque je vais
je sais pas moi dans un magasin je me
fais contrôler d'entrain opta qu'on fait
ça c'est très pratique alors le ds
extrême s'est fait de l'ops king c'est à
dire qu'en fait si vous avez une qualité
sonore qui est pas complètement dingues
les sardines à augmenter sa venir
compenser en fait ce que vous n'avez pas
pour rajouter améliorer la qualité alors
c'est pas de la magie c'est une techno
dub skelling qui fonctionne plutôt pas
mal an l'application à contrer
rapidement parce qu'il n'y a pas de
grande grande nouveauté ici contre
adaptative du son bon pourquoi pas moi
je suis pas un très grand fan mais on
peut la mettre si on le souhaite on va
pouvoir effectivement retrouvé this à
réduction de bruit ici directement donc
lâché les remises vont en plus du tout
soit le son ambiant vous choisissez le
niveau de son ambiant que vous allez
lire injecté j'ai dû mettre un maximum
soit carrément vous désactivez toute
l'électronique et ça peut être assez
intéressant le fameux parler pour chat
est ce qu'on a par le speak to chat
qu'on retrouve ici avec la sensibilité à
la voix et puis ce huit ans de fermeture
bon voilà c'est plutôt pas mal les quoi
l'isr qui est pour moi un truc vraiment
vraiment fort ici parce qu en fait j'en
ai plusieurs j'ai désactivé vous avez
deux niveaux personnalisé mais ça c'est
pareil c'est pas tout nouveau surtout
qu'on avait déjà avant ici les
paramètres de connexion bluetooth
priorité la qualité sonore en face à la
garde tous ses duels d'acné comme moi
ici je suis assez bon voyez ça peut
changer bien l'histoire ou priorité une
connexion stable c'est à vous de voir on
active ici le dfco extrêmes on peut
venir connecter simultanément deux
appareils si vous le souhaitez donc
c'est plutôt pas mal l'assistant vocal
alors moi j'en ai pas configuré parce
qu'il prend pas en charge syrie je vais
avoir amazon alexis qui va pouvoir
revenir à voir et google assistant
également les réglages du fonctionnement
envoyé je peux venir avec le bouton je
peux même même carrément le passé
activer le désactiver bon en fait je
peux changer mais bon voilà je viens
d'être là et puis après j'ai aimé aimé
couquet access regarder appuyé deux fois
sur un bouton appuyer trois fois sur un
bouton et ensuite je peux venir choisir
ce que ça ne fait envoyer spotify enfin
bref voilà donc j'ai le choix j'ai pas
mal de petites choses venir régler les
paramètres ici et ça c'est plutôt bien
ton automatiquement c'est s'interrompt
en retirant le casque dit vos cages
lemmy en français les mises à jour voilà
donc la pile je trouve assez
intéressante on a pas mal de petites
choses on a différents services et puis
vous pouvez avoir également le 360
reality huzhou que moi j'ai pas activé
ici j'ai pas de tin d'alger pas tous ces
services là donc forcément ça n'a pas
fonctionné mais je trouve que la pluie
allait quand même vachement bien et très
très bien construit donc pour avoir une
bonne expérience connectée pour moi
c'est une des meilleures applis que j'ai
pu rencontrer aujourd'hui en tout cas
souvent un casque côté autonomie il n'y
a pas de changement en tout cas c'est ce
que nous annonce sonne ici on va avoir
30 heures de musique exactement comme
sur le 1000 x n 4 et aux trois minutes
de charge vous êtes parti pour trois
heures des coûts tout en sachant que
vous avez de la quidditch charge en usb
c'est avec power d ivry alors j'ai pas
fais mois de tests comparatifs j'ai pas
fait de tests d'autonomie en l'utilisant
pendant des heures essayer ça si vous
voulez aller voir les tests d'autonomie
je vous invite à aller voir les tests de
mes potes médias journalistes qui eux
auront poussé le teste vraiment
extrêmement loin par rapport à
l'autonomie qui vous diront combien de
temps ils ont obtenu mais de toute façon
et ce qui est sûr c'est qu'un casque
comme ça même si aux annonces 30 30
heures mais si vous n'aviez pas trop
tard même si vous aviez 25 heures et
même 21 on va l'utiliser pour quoi on va
utiliser le plus long que j'ai fait
moins qu'un casque d'être 11 heures pour
un vol et même si je met plusieurs vols
boutabout j'arrive quoi 20 ans maximum
maximale et lorsque vous avez dans le
pire des cas une escale vous le prenez
vous le reprocher mais vous êtes parti
donc en termes d'autonomie vous pas de
problème il se recharge rapidement et ça
c'est extrêmement pratique je reviens
juste sur le côté application parce
qu'un truc dont je vous ai pas parlé ça
y est t'es sur le music simple 4,1 me
semble-t-il menace a disparu de
l'application si vous savez le fait de
pouvoir régler sa pression atmosphérique
alors c'est une connerie probablement
mais j'étais une pression trop sec
c'était peut-être de je sais pas combien
c'était un bar ou un truc comme ça je
puisse calculer en bas avec le mg 3 mlx
n 4 et lorsque je prenais l'avion il
venait légèrement le modifier j'étais à
0,8 il ya plus dans l'application alors
est-ce qu'on utilisait réellement à ce
qui est réellement un sens ou pas ce que
c'est et gadgets très probablement mais
pour un mec comme moi qui suis un peu
technophiles j'ai l'impression qu'on
m'enlève un truc alors est-ce que ça
reviendra sur une mise à jour peut-être
allez savoir est ce que c'est vraiment
handicapant et la réponse est clairement
non donc verdict ce casque je le trouve
plutôt bien je suis un peu frustré du
côté le casque qui se plie plus à côté
de ça est ce que c'était vraiment
intéressant et important non ça bien
supprimé quelques petits bruits
parasites qu'on ne retrouve plus donc ça
c'est plutôt sympa ce format ce design
j'aime bien parce qu'en fait je trouve
que ça le rend un peu plus plus léger un
peu plus contemporain il vient vraiment
bonifiée on reste dans l'adn d'un casque
de bose et je trouve qu'il vient
vraiment s'en rapprocher pour autant je
trouve très léger très design gens
regrettent légèrement ce petit point
d'un confort sur le dessus le fait de
mettre 8 micron versus 4 je sais pas si
ça change vraiment grand chose le fait
d'un passé d'un diaphragme de 40 mm un
diaphragme de 30 mm ça change vraiment
grand-chose clairement je ressens pas de
grosse différence allait coup pareil le
fait d'avoir doublé à le nombre de micro
pour les as qualité des appels
téléphoniques bas pour moi ça fait le
taf alors ils ont rajouté un truc
également au niveau des assistants
vocaux se sont à peyrat les white world
ce sont les mots pour venir utiliser en
fait sans les mains directement votre
votre casque bon ok c'est gadget ça
avance pourquoi pas le fait d'avoir la
charge en usb pour délivrer ce aussi un
plus le fait d'avoir un capteur amélioré
au niveau
du port de détection c'est un plus mais
ça c'est des petites mises à jour qu'il
fallait faire pour moi la vraie grosse
mise à jour ici sur ce cast ses dunes le
prix qui augmentent par rapport aux
autres tarifs au moment où ils ont lancé
les produits notamment sur le mythique
scène 4,6 m3 qui était tous les deux au
même tarif au niveau du lancement quand
on est quand même beaucoup plus cher et
puis surtout ce design donc je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui le mx 5 4 et le mythique
cm3 également reste très actuelle donc
si vous voulez vous voulez vous les
trouverez beaucoup moins cher et ça de
très joli casque si maintenant vous
voulez le très haut de gamme de sony
avec un nouveau design et qu'il vous
plaît plus que le design qu'on avait
avant voyez c'est un design qui est
ouvert là le casque ils souffrent par la
banque comme les ingés voyez on vienne
mettre là donc bon voilà c'est surtout
si vous voulez ce design si vous voulez
ça comme ça si ça vous plaît c'est pour
ça mon avis qu'il faut y aller le savoir
faire de sony la maîtrise audio la
réduction - actifs actions d'une très
très bonne qualité le confort au niveau
du cou signer en hausse et un peu moins
ça mais voilà ça reste un casque de très
bonne facture se trouve beaucoup trop
cher j'ai passé beaucoup trop semblait
très très cher 420 à 450 le rouge est
pas le prix exact de suite mais ça sera
dans cette fourchette de prix c'est en
tout cas ce que m'a dit sony alors moi
je trouve bien bien réussi très très
joli casse est ce que je pourrais vous
le recommander je pourrais vous le
recommander dès lors que vous avez le
budget avec là dessus mais de la même
manière que je vous recommanderais
encore d'aller sur le 1000 x n 4 ou le
mg 3 qui reste de très bons casques avec
un super confort c'est un peu différent
au niveau du design mais on reste dans
la lignée de ce que ces phares sony et
qui est très bien maîtrisée il n'y a pas
de grosse différence au niveau de
l'application c'est toujours un peu la
même chose sauf d'un point de vue
esthétique il a de la gueule franchement
là vraiment de la gueule je trouve très
très beau et je les aime bien je trouve
très j'ai même pour aller faire du sport
je vous dis tout faire
[Musique]
j'ai pas été déçu il est très cool voilà
donc est-ce que ce 1105 pourrez vous
tenter si oui dites le moi aux
commentaires et sinon dites moi qu'est
ce qu'il vous plairait pas par rapport
aux autres casques déjà de sony ericsson
4 mx m3 et également par rapport à
d'autres grands concurrents notamment
bosse pour vient souvent opposés au haut
de gamme chez sodi marque éléments
commentaires et non se retrouve très
vite pour continuer à parler de teck
pascal plein de choses qui arrivent je
le dis plein plein plein de trucs et
puis à cette vidéo 72 heures dans ma vie
en fin de ma vie perso mais ma vie si
perso dans le cadre de ce que je fais
enfin voyez vous emmener avec moi y'a
des coulisses ça c'est cool allez on en
parle bisous au tchad
[Musique]
il
où